on l'a quitté en larmes le coeur brisé
devant le feu qui crépite c'était l'an
dernier call me by her name
récit d'un premier amour le temps d'un
été naissance d'un désir et naissance
d'un phénomène timothée chalamet il ya
eu cette révélation absolument
incroyable dans call me bâillonner
là on se le prend dans la gueule dire on
est en empathie immédiate avec ce
personnage
amine d'ange son petit air de chatons
ont vite ébloui les plateaux télé le
pedigree de charles mai a attiré la
curiosité mère américaine père français
lui n'était pas le dernier à s'amuser
d'avoir été d'un coup propulsé en pleine
lumière
mais il n'a pas fallu longtemps pour que
le nom de timothée chalamet soit sur
toutes les lèvres
son destin à jamais lié au film de luca
guadagnino qui lui a valu à 22 ans
d'être le plus jeune de l'histoire nommé
à l'oscar du meilleur acteur et genre à
des monstres isa movistar cc et ses
matisse est de retour sur grand écran il
impressionne encore dans un rôle de john
key my beautiful boy
nouvelle performance saluée par la
critique on a rencontré timothée
chalamet in french
je ne sont pas déstabiliser et 1
je me sens très con digoin gratitude ces
ions français il est reconnaissant et
reconnaissable parmi mille portrait d'un
millennium prêt à conquérir le siècle
il n'était déjà pas bien gros mais il a
perdu 8 kg pour interpréter nick un
jeune homme pris dans l'enfer de la
drogue sous le regard impuissant de son
père
timothée chalamet joue le fils de steve
carell dans my beautiful boy adapté de
l'histoire vraie de nick chef qui après
avoir survécu à de longues années
d'addiction a raconté son calvaire dans
un livre j'ai essayé de passer le plus
tôt possible avec nez qui joue dans ce
film mais il ya vingt ans que j'étais
avec ce film parce que c'était quelqu'un
de vrai c'est un vrais humains et
indépendants des thèmes très sérieux de
drogue d'addiction c'était un histoire
de père et 6 tellement minces dreadlocks
et
ce livre de nec
c'est du point de vue de quelqu'un qui
est dans une addiction qui est tellement
à dicter au home est une drogue qui n'a
pas la possibilité de penser en arrière
ni en avance c'est dans le dans le
moment c'est il faut que je vois ici il
faut que je vais ici où je vis ici alors
c'était vraiment et donc comme acteur
parce qu'on essaye comme acteur de
penser comme ça dans les scènes
musicales
comme toute armée
timothée xala mais c'est quelqu'un qui
séduit par ses fragilités par par ses
failles
d'ailleurs il séduit les garçons comme
les filles c'est un séducteur sans le
les apparats désuet de du séducteur
qu'on pouvait connaître avant la
performance dans my beautiful boy fait
l'unanimité timothée chalamet fort de sa
double culture a ce je ne sais quoi qui
saisit la caméra c'est un acteur à la
fois francophone et anglo-saxons et j'ai
l'impression qu'il a pris le milieu des
deux formations possibles c'est à la
fois y'a rien il ya un vrai sens du
texte du mot de la littérature dans sa
façon de jouer ces accords c'est un
accord qui vraiment prend les
personnages à bras le corps ce qu'elle
me dire et qui a pas peur de jouer avec
à bord deux joissains carnation là avec
ce physique sensualité avec my beautiful
boy il s'ancre définitivement comme l'un
des acteurs les plus prometteurs de sa
génération
j'arrive à le jumeler un peu avec
leonardo dicaprio qui aux avants titanic
a incarné des adolescents mal dans leur
peau avec des familles dysfonctionnelles
d'ailleurs beautiful boy n'est pas sans
rappeler basketball diaries qui était un
film sur la drogue avec un leonardo
dicaprio complètement rongé par la
diction et on retrouve un petit peu je
sais pas à 7
on croirait presque qui marche dans ses
passes son parcours est un sans faute
depuis ses débuts de rom landes
et oui le fils du vice président des
états unis c'était lui le petit prince
de washington qui sortait avec la fille
de brody
la gérance quant à son tout premier rôle
au cinéma
c'était chez christopher nolan en 2014
interstellar
elle
matthew mcconaughey en maternelle mais
une apparition très courte
il l'a confessé à emma stone sur un
divan bon la blessure a était cicatrisée
j'ai toujours voulu être acteur et
j'avais compris en allant au lycée au
lycée d'acteur que tu te ronge tous
binet business pas pour être sur les
tapis rouges me pour le faire pour le
faire on souffre pas en souffrent mais
de comprendre que souvent c'est en
souffrant même au niveau économique
c'est très difficile comme acteur de
payer le loyer tout ça alors quand j'ai
commencé simplement à avoir la
possibilité de payer mon loyer ça c'est
le late a déjà gagné il peut désormais
se permettre d'annoncer en pleine
tempête me to kill revers son salaire
perçu sur un film de woody allen à des
associations de lutte contre le
harcèlement pas mal de like sur un stade
c'est en tout cas dans le cinéma
indépendant que son talent s'épanouit
porté par des réalisateurs souvent
européens d'ailleurs le belge felix van
groeningen pour my beautiful boy
l'italien luca guadagnino pour coakley
bayonnais d'avoir la possibilité de
travailler sur les projets que je trouve
à une intégrité à au niveau des thèmes
que c'est pas des projets cynique non
plus un violent pour être cool je sais
pas mais que j'espère ce sont des
miroirs à des problèmes ou des
phénomènes à dans notre société en
france aux états unis et que la réponse
en regardant ce film c'est de se
comprendre comprendre le monde un petit
peu
il embrasse et sans retenue son rôle
d'elliot dans le col me by name cet
adolescent qui se découvre fou de désir
pour un homme joué par armie hammer
[Musique]
xala met en garde le souvenir d'un
tournage idyllique en italie dans cette
europe qui ne cesse de lui faire des
clins d'oeil depuis qu'enfant il y
passait ses vacances
on a tourné ça en italie dans un civil
qui s'appelle tréma qui était un proche
d'un sens dans mon expérience tous mes
étés en grandissant en france dans une
village qui s'appelle au chambon sur
lignon dans l'eau thouars où je passe
mes étés d'un manière pas très loin
daliot en lisons dans soleil en faisant
le tisane
c'était pas une histoire sauf au niveau
des pêches n'était pas un effort qui
était loin de mon expérience
timothée restera pour toujours ce garçon
à la pêche un acteur associé au souvenir
de nos premiers émois comme si l'ado qui
sommeille en nous avaient trouvé sur
grand écran
sap le juste incarnation
[Musique]